with the resignation of president
gotaber rajapaksa ranil vikrama singha
the prime minister has been appointed in
an acting capacity as president but
there has to be a long-term arrangement
and the constitution sets down the
process for doing so no longer than
seven days after the president's
resignation must parliament
elect by secret ballot his successor
that would then serve the remainder of
the presidential term
so far we have basically four
nominations for the post of president
and we're being told that on the 19th
those nominations will be submitted to
parliament formally with the election
taking place on the 20th that individual
who is chosen by the 225 members of
parliament will be the successor to
president godard rajapaksa and serve as
president like i said until the end of
the presidential term and that president
will then call on an individual that has
shown that he has majority support in
parliament to set up and created
government and become prime minister so
that's the process that we will see
being played out over the next few days